ladies and gentlemen would you look at
this we've got a wedding chapel are you
kidding me
oh my gosh Kosmic this is incredible
[Music]
the way she's got the fenced area all
around the town square right there guys
look at the heart look at her waving
from down below
look everyone that she is hello
cosmic cosmic is gonna show us around
guys so I'm loving the the little hedges
here we got the hedges here all right so
we're gonna head to the left here got
this nice little terracotta heart she's
created a little pool here we got the
logs here look at this you could just
have a nice little romantic date with
someone right here got the little
statues right here outside Oh some nice
little information about the insects
currently featured at the alternate
museum yeah even though it's called
lecture hall bench I feel like this one
has a lot of uses this fountain is so
versatile it goes well in a lot of
different places then we got the little
dinosaur sign over here very nice very
nice oh man all right so dinner and a
movie
she's playing some music here look at
this little stand right here I love this
she's got the little menu out here oh
and then you go and overlook the pool
just wonderful just wonderful all right
here we go across the little stone
bridge stone bridges man this is what I
need I need these park benches right
here I need a couple of those park
benches so we're gonna make our way into
the orchard now and see yeah she's got
she's got a nice nice amount of space
between each of them here got the dirt
paths all in here the fenced in area a
fossil out in the wild got a nice little
flower area here with the garden hose
got to have that garden hose very
important it's got to make sure they
stay watered yeah and I see I found a
couple of people that have the little
designs for paths like this ladies and
gentlemen would you look at this we've
got a wedding chapel Oh
are you kidding me would you look at
this folks oh look here she plays will
pretend I'm the bride here we go
mrs. racket or are you are you ready to
renew our vows are you would you come
here mrs. racket or we can we can renew
our vows here in alterna at cosmics
chapel or i could sit back and attend
cosmics wedding oh my gosh cosmyk this
is incredible
[Music]
just-just-just magnificent magnificent
all right we make our way up and oh this
a very nice photo op here you've got
everyone from the wedding hey guys time
for pictures let's let's head on up here
we get the nice little overlook if this
is not a five-star Island ladies and
gentlemen then I don't know what is I
don't know what is all you can't start
the fire oh you can't start the fire
when you're a guest hmm
love it got the little gumball machine
outside nice touch very nice touch right
there dude we should just start doing
this every stream man just going to
visit different people's Islands yo
hello there your town is 5 stars
oh here we go okay we got a kids area a
sand castle look at that make our way up
the ramp oh this is a nice view right
here
ah and here we have made it to cosmics
home I'm guessing she's got a little her
mailbox out here got her workbench over
here her humble abode here we could just
sit back relax look at this fireplace
over here like this this is classy
classy very nice Wow would you look at
this this like spa sauna area oh look at
this we have the nice room for the kids
kind of like a playroom slash workroom
craft room
I've got a nice little spot for a bed up
there got got a spot to work here the
jewelry is here oh very nice this is the
kitchen here it looks like we've got
some things getting warm right now in
the crock pot or pressure cooker or yeah
one of the one of those things you know
got the cushions to sit down and enjoy
your meal very nice she's got the
ice-cream cone in the corner over there
love it anywhere the ice cream is
featured fantastic just absolutely
glorious oh my goodness I remember these
things I remember these dude if that
doesn't scream 90's right there I don't
know what does she's been painting her
toes guys
she's been painting her toes over here
dude this came as so many items
this is a study very formal I feel like
I get it I could get a lot of work done
in here got the chalkboard over here you
need jot down some ideas got the
hourglass and also a nice foosball table
dude I love the wall all the bookshelves
I had this little grasshopper do too
oh man I love that the grasshopper head
but all I've got to say to cosmic is
hats off just a phenomenal phenomenal
home that you have here oh she wants me
to go this way okay she wants me go this
way we're heading heading down
oh look at this the waterfalls on both
sides as you walk across very nice touch
very nice touch
oh yeah glad you showed me that yeah we
don't want to miss that got a little
fire pit here some lawn chairs the
cooler very nice very nice I need to
make a nice beach restaurant my wife and
I our honeymoon they had this great
restaurant right on the beach there's a
nice little place to play chess all
right well cosmic if you don't have
anything else I am I am just so
impressed spectacular work that you've
done here everything is kind of mapped
out like cosmic gave me the tour but
even if I even if she wasn't giving me
the direct tour you can kind of find
your way through most of the parts
because of how everything is so well
crafted using mostly these these hedges
right here I want to give her an
encouraging give her an encouraging word
because this is just a phenomenal island
actually can I wave should I wave
goodbye you guys